Бурим ведмедям Михасику та Любочці дуже пощастило.
Любочку врятували з цирку після двох років
знущань у тісній клітці. Михасик майже три роки
мусив розважати гостей ресторану.
У притулку "Біла скеля" на Житомирщині
ведмеді нарешті радіють життю.
Бавляться у водоймах та, майже як у природі,
шукають собі поживу. Працівники "Білої скелі"
реабілітують ведмедів, яких визволили активісти.
- Там гуманного ставлення мало.
Забиті внутрішні органи, бо вони мають неправильний раціон,
плюс їм часто дають пити алкоголь.
Тварини дуже швидко стають алкоголіками,
у них хвора печінка і в нас
майже всі тварини - на ліках
У сусідньому вольєрі ведмідь Синочок
без цілі ходить туди-сюди.
Дев’ять кроків направо, стільки ж - наліво.
Зрозуміти, що тепер він не в клітці, ведмідь не може.
Після восьми років у цирку у нього розвинулася
стереотипія, або розумова відсталість.
- Він настільки забитий, що він не розуміє, що він ведмідь.
Він не має тої поведінки, яка має бути в ведмедя.
Вирішити проблему з експлуатацією диких тварин
на законодавчому рівні спробували ще рік тому.
Тоді Верховна Рада ухвалила деякі поправки
до закону "Про захист тварин від жорстокого поводження",
дала визначення поняттям "жорстоке поводження"
та "пересувний звіринець".
Утім, парламент не заборонив їх.
- Мені здається, що глобальна проблема в тому, що
більшість депутатів не бачать у цьому важливості,
актуальності і нагальності. Тобто сотні тисяч
життів тварин для них не є питанням,
яке має бути швидко вирішене.
Зооактивісти зрозуміли: повної заборони
використання диких тварин в українських цирках
вони поки домогтися не можуть, тож намагаються
добитися поступових обмежень, влаштовуючи
періодично акції протесту.
Законопроект, який лобіюють нині,
звужує перелік видів тварин, яких дозволено
використовувати на притравочних станціях.
А також забороняє види деяких циркових програм.
Наприклад, вогняне шоу.
У минуле має піти й жебракування
з дикими тваринами та надання фотопослуг.
- Не хвилюйтеся, зі своїм котом удома ви можете
робити скільки завгодно селфі.
Я сподіваюсь, що для цього ви його не будете мучити.
Питання полягає в тому, що коли тварина
перетворюється на інструмент заробітку,
тут починають виникати проблеми.
Бо про що найбільше бізнесмени
починають задумуватись: як збільшити прибутки,
як зменшити витрати. А як зменшити витрати?
Значить, треба гірше або менше годувати тварину,
треба утримувати її в меншому просторі.
Якщо законопроект нарешті розглянуть
у парламенті та схвалять, це покращить долю,
наприклад, цього ведмедя в одному з
ресторанних комплексів під Києвом.
Це одне з понад 70-ти відомих зооактивістам місць,
де диких тварин утримують у жорстоких умовах.
У "Білій Скелі" тим часом ще є місця для кількох ведмедів.
Поки закону немає, забрати з неволі вдається лише
тих тварин, власники яких ідуть на співпрацю.